pour à l'est d'ottawa gatineau il suffit
de traverser un pont
ici les gens ont l'habitude de passer
d'une province à l'autre sans trop y
prêter attention
cette résidente d'ottawa traverse du
côté québécois pour sa marche
quotidienne
devra-t-elle changer son parcours fermé
avec la montée des cas et la propagation
des variants une certaine méfiance
s'installe entre les voisins
la proximité avec l'ontario a poussé ce
gatinois à se faire immuniser plus
rapidement pour ça je mets ma femme
vaccinée elle n'est pas la seule à être
inquiète les autorités de la santé de
l'outaouais sont aux aguets
faut-il revenir à des barrages outils
entre le québec et l'ontario comme lors
de la première vague
advenant que la situation ne se
stabilise fois c'est une mesure que on
devra regarder
présentement la faisabilité de mettre en
place des points de contrôle aléatoires
est à l'étude au niveau provincial
la santé publique du québec confirme
être en discussions avec les autres
provinces et les autorités fédérales sur
un possible resserrement des contrôles à
sa frontière
des élus de l'outaouais pour monter la
pression chez nous merci merci
on n'était pas en rouge foncé le nous là
dans deux semaines on a basculé pour
l'instant le gouvernement legault écarte
les contrôles routiers à ce moment ci
nous ne prévoyons pas instauré de
barrage ou procéder à la fermeture de
nos frontières avec les autres provinces
notamment l'ontario écrit le bureau de
la ministre de la sécurité publique du
québec
fox priest et rendent le premier
ministre de l'ontario continue de miser
sur la bonne volonté des citoyens
[Musique]
on évite les résidents de chaque
province à rester chez eux dit il
nous sommes dans une situation critique
limitée ou pas la circulation entre les
deux provinces
quand la population les avis sont
partagés d'autres sont prêts à sacrifier
leur habitude ils devraient fermer un
souhait que tous partagent peu importe
la province ici louis blouin radio
canada ottawa